so Augustine's Confessions why is it
called confessions he is confessing some
things
all right who's was he confessing them
to the reader does he need your approval
or need you to understand some people
write confessions like that he's really
talking to God and he's trying to make
sense out of his screwed-up life which
is still screwed up even after his
conversion to Christianity and living as
a Christian for for several years so why
why is he writing this he tells us that
at a certain point in book two that says
who am i narrating all of us - not to
you God but to my own kind in your
presence - that small part of the human
race who may chance to come upon these
writings turns out to be a much larger
part of the human race than he expected
and to what end that all that I did all
who read them they understand what
depths there are from which we are to
cry on to thee for what is more surely
heard in that year that then a
confessing heart and a faithful life
yeah he's using this metaphor that's
coming from the songs of crying from the
depths and you notice over and over
again in this text he says things like
I'm a riddle to myself I'm a mystery and
he's not trying to you know be the
precious about this you know I'm a
mystery I'm a special snowflake or
anything like that you know kind of
stuff that people say - trying to build
your self-esteem
he's saying I don't understand what the
hell's wrong with me yeah I understand
some of the things that are wrong with
me and every time I probe I go a little
bit deeper and wow there's even more
screwed up crap down there and how can
you figure this sort of thing how well
you know living in part and paying
attention what you're doing but thinking
about it and writing it down
is a way to try to puzzle it out to make
sense of it this is why some people
Journal that maybe a journal or writing
a diary and do it you know sometimes
that's helpful because you actually when
you put something down in front of
yourself you're able to get a picture of
it for yourself that you're not when
you're looking just but then within
yourself or have any of you ever been
told by friends or family here's what's
screwed up about you and here's what I
don't understand about the way you
behave imagine a few parents yeah I mean
you guys are just you know a few years
under the adolescence so that was the
time for I think I would imagine quite a
few of you where you were not only a
mystery to yourself but to everybody
else around you you're still trying to
figure some of this stuff out so
Augustine is somebody that we can we can
relate to pretty easily why am I having
you read this text well you know he does
talk a lot about love love is gonna be
really central he also talks a lot about
desire something that we haven't talked
about that much he had he talks about
friendship in some really important ways
and he compares and contrasts different
friendships that have been central in
his life with some of the earlier
authors we saw them talking about
friendship here's what friendship is
here's what it's like here's how it
works but it really wasn't until we got
to Cicero that we saw somebody saying
here's a friendship that that's showed
me what friendship did and it changed my
life and look at those people over there
I'm going to name some names their
friendships are screwed up
the people who follow Tiberius Gracchus
and went against their own you know
homeland and we're traitors and said I'm
doing this because I'm friends that
screwed up their life while I'm esteem
is doing something like that raised to a
much higher level you know for instance
and telling us about the pear tree and
asking himself what the hell was I doing
he's probing into the nature of man
friendship and then in looking at the
friend of his who died and his deep
grief and what it did to him
and what was what was really underlying
that again he's probing the nature of
friendship and then later on he has some
better friendships and he actually lives
with a bunch of friends and he reflects
on that that can teach us something and
Augustine is teaching us through telling
us about his own life so I think it's a
little bit easier to relate to I think
Elias teen is also very easy for you to
relate to because he is somebody who
actually has desires like us he
struggles for years and years and years
with some of his desires and you know
some of them he's not he doesn't a
problem food you know he has a problem
with sexual desire as a matter of fact
he even wants to sort of have it both
ways all the way through recognizing
yeah I should probably should convert
and live with you know you know filled
you the philosophical life or a
Christian life but I don't want to give
up having affairs we're having a
mistress at least I think I can do both
at the same time you know burn the
candle at both ends as we say and
doesn't work out for him but he has to
learn this sort of stuff by actually
trying to make it and he learns by
looking at his friends too doesn't
because other companions so let's think
about Augustine's desires and I'm going
to use a couple different words their
desires loves
so what are they what does he start he
starts out with you know infancy and
childhood
I don't remember my infancy cuz I was a
little baby
do any of you remember being a little
baby no I mean I think there's something
normal about not remembering that kind
of thing and there's different theories
for why we don't remember that but you
have to get into those oh yes we learn
about other baby we learn about what we
were as a baby by other people telling
us or by looking at other babies yeah
how many of you have had a younger
brother or sister that you had to deal
with when they were a baby well if you
okay was it fun there were some [ __ ]
some fun walnuts right what was unfuck
aunt sometimes do that to drain a bite
your hair yeah bite your fingers plate
everything that there is why because a
baby is motivated by desire to to fight
things chew on things to digest them you
know they're basically one step up from
eating machines what else doesn't take
much to set a baby off and why obviously
was probably that why do you babies cry
because there's something they they want
that they're not getting out of babies
designers are just you know all over the
place they would eat everything they
possibly could they're like dogs in that
respect dogs will eat you know way more
than they want to if you let them that's
why you know you have to be kind of
circumspect about well how much food you
give them especially table scraps babies
will eat anything - I remember my son
when he was little my daughter I would
you know I would be watching her and
watching the TV
in the late afternoon and I'd have a
beer and I'd be drinking it and I like
very bitter beer so I would take it out
my finger and dip it in the beer yeah
you know touch it to her to her tongue
as you make that you know face and we
only did this a few times that's a
normal reaction bitterness babies don't
like bitterness my son as soon as I did
that he like latched on to my finger and
I thought well I better not do that at
all because this kid actually likes beer
already you know you don't want to
encourage that sort of conservatism it
turns out he's probably what we call a
super taster likes very bitter things
and who knows who knows what the
explanation is point--is babies have
these inordinate desires and that's why
they cry some of the things are
legitimate they want to be changed right
one reason they cry babies can cry for
no reason whatsoever and then you try to
comfort them and sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't
my daughter I actually had to put her in
the car and drive for miles to get her
to stop crying and go to sleep sometimes
that's what it took it's good thing we
have cars it's something likes I don't
know what I would have would have done
in those cases what happens after you
quits being an infant what does he start
to desire what do you what do you
remember there's another thing too I
mean not just quick desires but also the
flip side that is fears fears
he has to go to school right is school a
pleasant experience for st. Augustine
not saying I see a little Augie where is
he tell you about going to school again
you might believe to get them not at the
beading part I hope have you were beaten
in school he was why was he beat just
for the sheer fun of it
schoolmasters you know got a taste for
the flash wanted to initiate him and
some of the you know British puck lot of
schools kind of looked like that
they wanted him to learn right and if he
he didn't wanna learn what did he want
to do what did you want to do as a kid
what's up play yeah and he talks about
games where you know he's off with his
friends and even with that there's
rivalries you want to win right you want
to be on top his parents want him to
learn the school master wants him to
learn Augustine is not really that
interested in learning at that point is
he he's even less interested when they
beat it you know he doesn't learn Greek
because he's got a Greek teacher who was
cruel to him learning is not yet
something that he desires but that play
what else does he desire
yeah
what else is he on the lookout
look
companionship is that is that something
important to you when you're in first
grade second grade third grade I know
it's going back many ways was that very
important for you yeah at least one
right and then you know that's nice too
you have other kids that do especially
that one friend
like playdates yeah you know that was
something different for your generation
we didn't have playdates we had go over
to so-and-so's house you know get out of
my hair
we didn't have anything like my play
dates but it makes sense of the kind of
environment that we live in now to
schedule these
what happened when he hits puberty his
father figures out that he's hit puberty
because they're in public baths which is
a big thing that night
Romans Augustine was living in North
Africa it's Roman culture parsing by the
way is not wrong he's almost like one of
senator from some of the local tracks
and his father sees him in the bath and
realizes that he's turning into a young
man and how does he describe him I mean
let's look at some of the things that
did he says he says
this is the beginning of book 2 I wish
now to review and memory my past
wickedness and the carnal corruptions of
my soul cetera as I became a youth I
longed to be satisfied with worldly
things so some of these are worldly
things and we'll look at some other
worldly things and dared to grow wild in
a succession of various and shadowy
loves what was it the delighted me saved
to love and Bhima
so he had a desire and a desire to long
remember back to like seventh grade
eighth grade ninth grade and when you
know these these hormones are washing
over you and these feelings of I wish I
had somebody who I could like and you
know be affectionate with that's not
just about sexual desire he's going to
talk about in terms of sexual desire
there's also this sense of wanting
affection from somebody do you remember
like you know every past note still at
school and is that something they do
everything's done my text I don't know
back in our day used to be passing knows
and you get a note and it would say
so-and-so likes you when suddenly your
day has gotten a lot better hasn't
that's kind of a weird thing my health
because you know you've got some note
anything know if it's true or false
maybe somebody's just leading in life
but that feeling being being loved being
the object of attraction being the
object of affection for another person
that's something that you begin to
desire through puberty sometimes
children develop that earlier you know
because it's because of abuse that's a
little bit different
usually the normal development is you
become very interested in how other
people see you as a desirable object is
an object of affection and you also want
to exert that towards somebody else it's
not just wanting to get laid
it's not just wanting to you know
kissing your sacks or stuff like that
it's wanting to actually show affection
to another person very often you know
people are not quite sure how to do this
so you should push the girl down or
something like that you know get my
Valentine it's some nasty note and then
you say this isn't the way that you
actually do things if you want though
some people like them that you're going
about it the wrong way because what's
really going on in them is they they
want to exert affection towards somebody
else so harnessing says what is it that
delighted me safe to love and be loved
and so still I did not keep the moderate
way of the love of mind to mind the
right path of friendship instead the
mists of passion steamed up out of the
puggly conclude a sense of the flesh and
the hot imagination of puberty and they
so obscured and overcast my heart I was
unable to distinguish pure affection
from unholy desire okay what's going on
there he's flooded with hormones the way
that a kid is normally at that age he's
in a culture where all these other kids
are going through the same sort of thing
he's seeing all these attractive bodies
are all around and he's finding himself
attracted to them you know very common
behavior right and it is confusing isn't
it do you remember that that confusion
that comes with this or was it all just
crystal clear you know something some
switch flipped in your head and now
everything was totally clear Nia no but
most most of the time it's pretty
confusing when you become infatuated
with somebody you'd become a little
tongue-tied little clumsy around them
that's that's a sign of that confusion
working through you and he he talks
about you know this being a problem for
him throughout the rest of his life this
you know for him it ends up being sexual
desire what else does he want out of
life so I just mean just about playing
and having sex having friends
what other things come into his life
these later books well let's think about
this what does he go off to do so you
sit at home learn a craft what does he
do instead what were you guys sorry
honey for what let anybody here doing a
communications degree that's what ice
cream did back then they called it
rhetoric and in your con degree you will
actually be studying some of the classic
authors who were veterans because they
laid the foundations for study of
communication
now what is why is he going to school
why is he studying does he talk like he
enjoys it for its own sake that really
let's think about this why do you want
to go to school better than staying at
home that's that's not a very good
reason to go to Marist the freedom that
it brings yeah we want a successful
future
okay so we've talked about winning like
winning a game that's pretty trivial
stuff a successful future or something
much bigger what does that look like
what would be components of a successful
future I guess getting a job okay
success how do you know if you're doing
your job well whatever signs of that
that's a big my promotions yeah being
given more responsibilities usually
comes with promotions sometimes they
they screw you over and they give you a
different title and some more
responsibilities but no more money you
know your that's not really a promotion
that's just moving they call it a
lateral move what else
breeze yeah let's along the same lines
money we do need we do need well is that
all that people want out of their
careers if we're honest with ourselves
why why do people will say you know look
at how people become envious of each
other sometimes we can figure out that
good by looking at the officer but they
sometimes have become in this because
another friend gets a bigger paycheck
right that's a better title what else do
people get envious about in the
workplace yeah yeah
early seems happier right that's cuz
some people like you know cheerful face
all the time if one person seems to be
having a better time enjoying themselves
more that's that's part of it I think
all of you I hope when you're aiming for
your good career you want something that
will be enjoyable for you not just you
know lots of titles and money
responsibilities then you actually enjoy
what you're doing yeah yeah now it could
be the blocks or it could be like fellow
employees when people when you have a
better reputation when you have more
customers people get very upset about
these these sorts of things somebody
publishes an article and you know
everyone congratulate them and inside
some of their their peers feel envious
you know where there's these are the
sort of things that ordinary lives are
actually made of and Augustine is the
after that's part of being successful
for him
studying rhetoric will give him access
to the higher culture just like going
here to embarrass you know why is it
that going to college is portrayed in
our culture as the key to success just
any college as it turns out once you get
out you find out it doesn't matter where
you went to college people don't look at
degrees
and light you guys are doing good I
don't want to scare it but not every
college has a big reputation and part of
what part of what you know is really
good about Mara since they're very good
at connecting you to people who will
help you in your careers and help you
develop as though it's not professional
Augustine wants access to that that's
why he's going to school once he
actually graduates he becomes a master
and starts teaching and what does he
want with his teaching
a big big chair at Harvard no no he's
not so interested in that why does he
move from from city to city and teaching
post a teaching post is it to try to get
higher and higher positions done exactly
you know why I like teaching here at
Marist better than some of the other
places I've taught it's not because of
this classroom we've talked about that
before this class we can write I've
taught a few other crappy classrooms
here at MERIS although most Muslim
classrooms are pretty nice is that the
the accommodations in the cafeteria you
know we get cheaper meals over in the
cafeteria like half a lot no that's not
what attracted me the barest desks
Oh can we use I learned Lots places with
Sakai the great library I like the
library but there's you know if I if I
wanted to access a bigger library around
here I'm going to the faster a bard
might might have books that we don't
have over there why well it's not the
paycheck either as an adjunct I'm not
making a ton of money
ya know what about it mayor students
dress better right yeah I can learn
about the the ins and outs of culture we
talked about hipster culture a couple
days ago for class that's not what why
yeah especially the work out you guys
don't talk as much as students with a
lot of other places so it takes a lot of
work to get students talking I know that
you guys aren't thinking about that it's
because I see it in your writing when I
assign you guys work you do it a lot of
lot of schools that you go to they give
you a very hard time about it yeah they
won't they won't hand in the work and it
won't be up to standards most of the
students that I have in my classes do
the work and they learned a lot in the
process because when I designed the work
to help you learn and it's very you know
it's it's great I like reading your
papers because I can see you guys
thinking while I'm reading them and I
enjoy that I've never had to use that
part in the syllabus that we talked
about at the beginning of the semester
with if a student gets out of line I'll
kick them out of the class I've never
had to use it at Paris lots of other
places I've taught it can't kick
students out of class Augustine talks
about the students in Carthage it's like
a zoo they just come in and out of class
when everybody whatever they feel like
it they
they want you know they get the teacher
a hard time and so he's I'm getting the
hell out of here I'm going to roll I'm
going to a different place and then when
it gets to Rome are the students the
students are at least not doing that but
what do they do they don't pay the
teacher back then you have to actually
collect you know imagine that after each
class I like say okay I'm going to put
up the contribution jar here everybody
put in there their muddy now everyone
like you don't pretend I've got
somewhere to go
that's what happens to minute room and
they don't pay they says this isn't good
either I'm going to Milan I'm gonna
teach there he wants some snacks peace
of mind or use this word at different
points needs you wants things to go
along smooth is that something you guys
can relate to in your life I think so
something happens to him while he's you
studying and this may be the experience
for you you know I'm throwing some
classic text sent you that may be the
thing that works for you it may be
something you read it in another class
he reads Cicero's Hortensius and this
awakens him to the desire for knowledge
with which he thinks he's going to get
through through philosophy you know when
when you have that that experience of
some author or some text really opening
your eyes and it might not be Cicero
might not be Augustine for you who knows
what it's going to be it might be
somebody but I hope it happens for for
each one of you I know it's happened to
me a number of times because I've been
pretty lucky in that respect you you
become aware of this entire vast world
outside of yourself and outside of the
sphere of your own desires and there are
higher things more lasting things and
when you become aware of that you become
infected you might say with desire for
that desire for the eternal desire for
the essential desire for what's really
real what's more real they have the
everyday humdrum activities that were
involved in filling in forms sitting in
desks all that sort of stuff sticking to
the schedule you become interested in
higher meaning and that's a that's
eventually going to lead them to God
Augustine you know this is the beginning
he's got a mom who's you know a Catholic
and as you know catechized him when he
was a kid being attached to that stuff I
mean when you read books one and two and
three it's pretty clear that none of its
stock all right otherwise you wouldn't
be taking a mistress having a kid by her
all these sorts of things trying to get
out of doing work what gets him moving
in that direction as this desire and
notice we have all these desires all
going on all at the same time and we
have to choose which ones we're going to
follow and if we don't choose other
things we'll choose for us because these
desires all push on us you know I mean
sexual desire is the one that obviously
struggles with the most and just think
about how strong that is think about how
hard it is for some people to get out of
bad relationships because they like
having sex with
person in that relationship even though
they can't stand that person otherwise
they still stay in that relationship
with them yeah or they can't keep
themselves out of relationships long
enough to actually follow through on any
of the other things that they want it's
a very strong designer it is for many
human beings a distro Agustin and if you
don't at some point take stock of your
desires and think about which ones you
want to follow which ones are actually
more worthwhile you're you're gonna get
drawn into all sorts of thickets you
might say and blind spots so we've
looked at artisans designers let's go
through his his life and some of the
high points in this section just a very
brief so we start off infancy childhood
then adolescence becomes aware of girls
you know and how much he likes them and
then what happens towards the the middle
of end of book two there's this pair
transcendence and we're going to come
back to that because that's a very
important part right there and this is
where he does something and it's just
totally incomprehensible to what the
hell is he doing he draws from some
lessons from that then he you know it
becomes a student in college becomes a
master eventually has some more
friendships experiences a terrible loss
that he's gonna tell us about on the way
discovers that he likes philosophy and
wants to learn more about it then he
ends up joining a cult this is something
that in order to make sense of what's
going on
manikyam manikyam was a gnostic religion
some people want to say it's a gnostic
form of christianity but it really it's
it's in its traditional form blending
not only christianity but also buddhism
in certain respects and a particular
form of zou asterism it's syncretic it's
blending together all sorts of religions
and honesty in turns to Mary key ISM
because it seems to provide some answers
to the questions that he's asking like
what is life all about what is most real
what should I be turning myself towards
a lot of people find these sort of the
answers in religion don't think instead
of in philosophy I'm not saying that
there's anything wrong with that - by
the way I on the record with that I
don't think everybody has to study
philosophy to grapple with these
questions I think that great literature
grapples with these questions I think
that every major world religion tries to
grapple with these questions I think
that if you study history well you're
trying to grapple with these questions
it's not necessarily just through
philosophy
Boxey is posed with these three choices
devote myself to philosophy philosophy
seems to provide more questions than it
does answers in many respects and PARCC
is not all the philosophers agree about
you know what you ought to be doing
there's Stoics there's play teenis
there's Aristotelian there's Epicureans
you notice in this class we've already
plumbed a number of different
philosophical values right mana key is
impervium to be like answers it's this
incredible cosmogony you know where evil
came from what the good is and here's
I'm going to go to in a very very
attenuated form Gnostic Christianity and
other forms of Gnosticism will say that
there the universe is fundamentally bad
that this was created by an evil force
not by a good force so salvation lies in
getting outside of the boundaries of
creation of creative being your bodies
are bad your souls are actually bad the
powers and principalities that rule over
everything they're bad they want to keep
you trapped here in this prison what
gets you out of that prison is some sort
of Savior
this is how they were able to bring
together Buddhism so astron ism and
christianity christianity who's the
savior being jesus right so astron ism
has these Nosa notions of the psycho
shanks these Saviour beings and Buddhism
by the time the third they're dealing
with it has all sorts of notions of
salvation coming up as well and you have
beings like not just the Buddha himself
but these other beings coming about in
my bosom deliberately develop themselves
to getting people out of this veil of
Fitness illusion this prison world that
we're in yeah so how do you practice
this well you know you can practice it
in a number of different ways and they
had their own sort of like church
hierarchy and it mentions a spouse's guy
houses as a bishop and it was kind of a
counter organization to Orthodox or
Catholic Christianity at the time and
what would really appeal to people about
manic ISM it felt like you were in the
know it felt like you were special
because you're hearing this message and
it's not for all those other dummies out
there who are you know like reading the
Bible or you know trying to just be good
people
you've got the message you've got the
secret that all those other poor saps
don't have and they may not have any
people in some versions of agnosticism
but you are you're valuable and you can
work your way towards getting out of
this it's an elitist sort of religion
have all sorts of other things rolled
into it and Augustine was unsatisfied
with the answers that he would get when
he to ask questions when he looked at
Christianity and when he looked at you
know the Christian scriptures at that
age he couldn't make much much sense of
them you notice that one of the key
themes that runs throughout this is that
one of the reasons why he rejected God
over and over and over again is because
he didn't really know what God was he
didn't have a good conception he had a
not only did he not have a good
conception it's really a fuzzy picture
he actually had the wrong conception of
what God was and so you know what he's
rejecting a lot of the time isn't what
God actually yes this is according to
agustin
same thing with the Scriptures they seem
kind of stupid you know there's there's
also to the seeming contradictions in
them and there's you know they're not
written in a very high style philosophy
that's kind of an elite activity too
it's written for these you know smart
people but you know
Bibles can a little class so I did have
daddy a cheese he's not ready so he
winds up being a man of kefir for quite
a while and he associates with some
friends and he you notice that he
actually converts one of his friends the
one who's later going to die away from
his Orthodox faith to manic ISM then he
goes back his friend goes back now one
of the other things I'm going through
this very quickly unfortunately because
I do want to get to some of these
incidents one of the other things that
you need one of the pieces of the puzzle
in order to make sense of what's being
said in the rest of this is what we
could call Augustine's let's call it his
ethics or his moral doctrine and the
basic idea is that there is a hierarchy
of
there are higher and lower guns so
having sex is kind of a lower good it's
fun it's a good thing you know even if
it produces children children are a bad
thing
you know like doggin says they compel us
to love them why because they are
lovable despite all the crying and you
know the constant need to be change
there's a couple of other stuff that
goes along with the biting things
ruining whatever it is that you set them
on good things aren't actually good
things having sex is a good thing
Augustine is an antibody the human
body's a good thing Candy's a good thing
why you like eating candy drinking beer
is a good thing but these lower threads
are only good when they're kept within
the proper context so you have to
continue and the human being has to
choose in all sorts of situations of
life are they going to go for the higher
goods or are they going to go for the
lower it is and what are we prompted by
desire and part of our nature as we are
right now there's a whole long story
about you know why does the case I'm not
gonna try to go into this now I'll just
say the words original set part of why
we're oriented bad would be at the start
is we have stronger desires for the
lower guns we don't automatically become
aware of our desire for philosophy for
example or something like philosophy
something like a meeting in life we all
know that we want to eat we want comfort
we want it you know once you're past
puberty we want to have sex we want
people to look up to us all those sorts
of things
lower goods in order to remain good have
to be arranged in an ordered
if they're pursued just for their own
sake they're pursued in a disordered way
and so something that's actually good
can become bad for us in certain
contexts let's let's take you know
drinking beer for example most of you
are underage so is there anything
inherently bad about you drinking beer
right now at 18
nobody's here still 17 right seventeen
nineteen is there anything inherently
bad about it no so you might actually
feel kind of like cheated dude you don't
get to drink beer people who are 21 did
that's an arbitrary limit it's an
ordering that was produced by our
society in part cos through trial and
error we figured out that if you let 18
year-olds drank all sorts of you know
terrible things happen more terrible
things than when you when you boost it
up to 21 but it doesn't have to be that
way other societies somebody did travel
abroad up until this point other places
you can drink right when I was in the
Army I could drink at 18 because there
weren't any laws about that those are
all state laws when I was overseas then
I came back and I wasn't quite 21 and I
couldn't drink it I felt cheated
there's an ordering there what's bad
about you drinking right now you're
breaking the law it's not about the beer
itself or the wine or the liquor pick
whatever you want there are some other
limits within the thing itself what
happens if you drink beer all day long
every day you can last year at Marist
just imagine trying to drink every
single day you know what your life would
be like you would change very rapidly
just you'd be so hung over after like a
week you couldn't stand you think either
that or you become like a hardcore
alcoholic you know couple son of other
fathers we could do this with any other
lower good what is the highest good for
Augustine it's actually going to be God
the most permanent the most foundational
good does all these other goods are good
including the human being because
they're coming originally from God God
is the one who knows the best can
provide us with the best insight into
what the proper order is to them but we
don't know how he's gonna automatically
listen and if somebody you know reads
you the Ten Commandments it doesn't
automatically produce conviction that
you shouldn't steal for example right it
takes it takes working on ourselves and
Augustine is attentive to our choices in
this matter with respect to the will
when we go wrong we do so by pursuing
lower goods in a disordered way and
ignoring the higher goods which should
be more valuable which could be not
necessarily God it could be friendship
could be a good you know when you
sacrifice a friendship for something
like money you're screwing things up
Augustine would say you're got a
disordered view of that
and it's not just in the intellect it's
in the will to near your Faculty of
choice and your will decide which
desires you're going to follow so this
is a good place to jump off down to the
pear tree
and then if we have time we'll talk
about the death of the friend
so Augustine is engaged in an act of
theft with a bunch of his friends isn't
it could have been Amanda listen could
have been cow tipping could have been
pick whatever the thing that you like
the kids do because kids are quite often
the drips all right
22:08 paint bring somebody's house you
know for no good reason whatsoever it
sound like they screwed you over just to
do it we're all familiar with that kind
of impulse right Augustine says to
himself so we took these pears and we
didn't even eat them we just gave them
to pigs and why did we do it because we
liked you like the act of theft we I
desired to steal why that's the big
question why what's the reason what's
the good why do people steal in a lot of
cases some people steal because they
need things and stealing is the easiest
way to get it right reason a lot of
people steal some people it becomes
their mode of life and you know there's
all sorts of other problems with
complications there maybe they could
have stolen the pears to do something
like bring them to the theater and throw
them at the the terrible you know actors
or something like that that would at
least be some reason to do it
well obviously is concerned because it
doesn't seem like there's any reason
outside of the sheer act of stealing
which is a is a bad-ass so it looks like
he is desiring
evil or the bad words on sake you know
who talks about murder why do people
kill each other people kill each other
because they get angry with each other
that's one big reason somebody sleeps
with somebody else's spouse they kill
the spouse or the other person people
get frustrated with each other they
shoot each other on the highway
sometimes people kill each other for
money or to have access to the goods
that the other person has they try to
kill competitors these are all bad
things to do but they're all pursued for
the sake of some sort of good to that
person who's doing it it's very rare
that you find somebody who says I just
like killing people I'm just into that I
mean even when they do that it's because
they get sexual satisfaction out of it
and so i'm you know perverted way or
it's about honor or something like that
it's very rare that you can find
somebody who says i just like killing
for its own sake the nice thing is doing
this was stealing so what's going on
there there's no good they don't need
these piers for anything it's not not
doing anything he doesn't actually need
to get in with these friends it's not
like an initiation right he's got
another possibility says well you know
if you think about different vices maybe
it's not some external object that I
wanted something I would come out of it
maybe I want to be act because there is
actually something desirable or
beautiful or significant about the act
itself so he says you know I'll think
about cried people who are prideful at
least it looks like they think a lot of
themselves and that could be in some
respects a good thing or if people are
spendthrifts they at least look kinda
like generous people you know there's
some semblance there's some shadow
beauty to it there's some shadow of
attractiveness to it he says was there
anything like that in my act no there
was nothing redeeming about it there was
nothing
you know pretty attractive cool about it
so what the hell is wrong with me why
did I do that fight if I did that sort
of thing then who knows what sort of
stuff I'm gonna do as an adult if I
could like go off the deep end and do
something wrong
just for its own sake what was going on
in there
and he puts his finger on it when he
starts looking at these different vices
and what's going on with them he calls
it a he says that there's there's a can
of counterfeit of freedom that occurs
with us I'm actually gonna read this
passage because it's quite quite good he
says what was it that I loved in that
theft I was imitating God in a certain
respect I was trying to make myself like
God that's a weird thing to say isn't it
jumping from I mean I was knocked down
some road signs and stuck him in
somebody's lawn why I was imitating cop
can you imagine somebody giving that
there's a the answer for why they did
what they did wrong why he tripped me
down I wasn't walking down the stairs
imitating God why it says I want to buy
that gesture to rebel against your law
to rebel against the moral code to repel
against right and wrong to place myself
above right and wrong even though I had
no power to do that I can't actually get
outside of morality altogether I'm kind
of stuck with that but I can actually
push against it and I can produce a kind
of what he calls counterfeit freedom by
doing with impunity deeds that were
forbidden in a deluded son set in a
sense of impotence what is attractive
about this doing wrong for its own sake
is it feels like power
feels like freedom feels like something
in a certain way
divine that's the kick that we get out
of being jerks or being horrific people
sometimes at the other extreme people
there are some people who do murder
other people just for the sake of
murdering them it's because they want
this there are people who break up a
relationship and cheat on their spouse
for no reason whatsoever other than
because they can do it and oftentimes
the justification that they give is I
wanted to feel alive I wanted to feel
something that's what they wanted to
feel the part of the Augustine and why
is this important so just you know this
is the screwed-up kid who did this you
know stupid the act of stealing pairs
and giving them to pigs something we
can't relate to no this is something
that lies within every single one of us
is a possibility at any given time this
is something he's revealing to us
something about human nature that most
of the time when we do bad things
there's a reason that's pretty easy to
come across I wanted some some good over
here that was going to come from it why
did I y'all laugh you know this person
because I wanted them to do this the
action that that would have been
beneficial to me right that sort of
thing why did I do this stupid thing
over here because I want to get in good
with these friends because I care about
what they think of me why did I do this
because my my significant other made me
feel embarrassed and I didn't want to
feel embarrassed I want to overcome that
so I had yelled at that before or you
know
made fun of that instead sometimes
there's things in the act itself that
make the act attractive once you develop
the habit for something for example you
know sometimes it's this and Augustine
goes on he says you know what this is
the theft was a nothing there was really
nothing involved in it was a way for me
to bring nothingness into the world so
what the hell is wrong with me again
well I was I wouldn't have done it if I
wasn't with those those stupid
companions so maybe I didn't really love
the theft maybe it was that I loved the
companionship the friendship he says
does that really hold that really
because I don't actually like those
people I don't care what they think I
know I wouldn't have done it on my own
but it's not like I did it to win their
approval because I don't even think that
they're worthy providing me untrue
they're just a bunch of dummies or
scumbags that I was slumming with and
did this stupid thing there are nothing
as well so there's two nothing's we
human beings and this is where it gets
very metaphysical have the capacity to
bring nothingness into the world as
opposed to what things are supposed to
be that's the lesson of the pear tree as
you read through it again some of these
points hopefully will come out to you he
talks about another incident that's very
important as well
Augustine is a very close friend by now
he's already chasing women and he is you
know getting himself involved in all
sorts of crazy stuff but he's also
developed a very good friendship and
actually but now he's actually father to
China to illegitimate hookup that turns
into like a lifelong affair he develops
his really close friendship and friend
dies and his whole life changes how many
of you had a close relative or friend
died in your life well about half of it
but everybody's going to have to go
through that sooner or later somebody
close to you about because mortality
rates a hundred percent yeah you died
before them they died for you the other
way it's kind of sucks what can we
actually learn from it why why do we
have the sorts of reactions that we do
you look at the way that he talks it
says my heart was utterly darkened by
the sorrow everywhere I looked I saw
down you guys those of you have gone
through a closed person somebody close
to you dying you know what this is like
you feel down gloomy it's very hard to
think about other things my native place
is a torture room to me and my father's
house a strange unhappiness you feel all
the source you feel like you don't fit
in it that's a normal reaction and then
he says my I saw him everywhere but they
did not see him and I hated all places
because he was not in them there's a
good that's lacking
and the lack of that good makes other
things bad same thing can happen with a
breakup too by the way you know you
you're close with somebody you have your
places and then you break up and now you
don't want to go back to those places
anymore because it reminds you of them
and they're not there and you can't you
know have that relationship anymore
even though it's bringing back good
memories it's also painful to you at the
same time we are we're full of these
sort of contradictions so he says I
became a hard riddle to myself and asked
my soul why she was so downcast and why
this disquieted me so sorely and then he
said she didn't know how to answer me if
I said hope in God which is probably his
mom said to him she properly disobey me
why because my conception of God wasn't
something that could actually fill in
the gap here what do I care about some
old guy in this guy he says nothing but
tears were sweep to me and I took my
friend's place in my heart's desire some
tears sweet
let's get balls his eyes out for days
and days and days which is actually good
for you it makes sense
manliness was not understood by a lot of
the ancients as precluding crying the
way that it has been understood and some
points in American culture
Odysseus cries he's a tough guy
Odysseus cries over his men as he's
rowing his lost companions if a discus
can cry it's okay for Augustine to cry
okay for for just about anybody right
why why is he crying what's he getting
out of it he says my tears took my
friend his place in my heart's desire so
that means that he
he says every soul is wretched
that is fettered in the friendship of
mortal things it's torn when it loses
them why is he so upset he made a
mistake remember a little bit earlier I
was talking about ordering of goods
friendship is at a very high good but
it's not the highest good and if you
expect that your friend is going to live
forever
or that your parents are going to live
forever or that your children are going
to live forever
at least in the bodily sense you're
really setting yourself up for some
sorrow because sooner or later everybody
does die things things break apart he
says if the soul is fettered in the
friendship of moral things is torn in
pieces when it loses them then it
realizes its misery for Augustine we're
not all just happy people all the time
why do we desire the things that we do
because they make us happy we don't want
to be unhappy instead you know when you
talked about wanting to be friends
having a close friend think of the
opposite of that
it's loneliness you're in a strange
place
why don't you do orientation for you
nightmares
so that you wouldn't feel as lonely
coming in as as you do when you first
get there Matt even made no friends
whatsoever how lonely that would be we
when your friend is taken away now you
realize how lonely you really are when
your other things you like you're taking
away you realize just how sad or hungry
or broken you actually off and you may
not have realized that before that good
came into your life and made it the
center of your life so he says I wept
most bitterly and I found a rest in
bitterness I was wretched and yet that
wretched life was dearer to me than my
friend I was more concerned about you
know my life than about
the loss of a friend because I would
have willingly have changed my life but
I was still more unwilling to lose it
than to have lost him he says I was
caught in this kind of trap
it was wearisome to live in a fearful
thing to die and he says that well I may
have been afraid to die my I was afraid
of dying as my friend would then die
wholly the one whom I so greatly loved
he says my heart became an unhappy
lodging where I could neither stay or
leave so what was going on there it was
putting his his love into things that
can't Felicia forth it and I was always
seen saying well don't get close to
anybody no but but realize that your
friend is not the highest good so if you
orient your life around
lower goods and make those the most
precious things in your life and you
never think about how your things you're
really setting yourself up for some
misery what gets him out of it
well what gets him out of it is what
tells you why friendship is so important
artist he says what revived and
refreshed me more than anything else was
the consolation of all their friends
that's why it's important to have more
than one friend right because what's
going to happen with that friendship
breaks up that's also important to why
when you get really attached to somebody
you know romantically don't quit hanging
out with the rest of your friends cuz if
you break up you're gonna need those
friends to have a shoulder to cry on
about how terrible your life is
happening both of that other person
exited your life he says with these
other friends and went on loving the
things that I loved yeah
what are these well he gives examples
discourse of discourse and joking around
isn't that fun talking with your friends
indulging in courteous exchanges reading
Pleasant books together try to live
together
he's just wasting time together being
earnest together being serious about the
same
things could be even like watching game
sports to differ at times without ill
humors a man might do with himself
sometimes teaching sometimes being
talking says this is what we love and
our friends this is what friendship is
really about losing a friend reveals to
us why friendship is such a good we love
it so much this is where Augustine is
going way beyond any of the people we
study we love it so much friendship that
a man's conscience accuses itself if he
does not love one who loves him
Augustine is saying that when somebody
is affectionate towards us we feel like
we want to be affectionate towards them
it's very easy in the case of like
sexual attraction in some cases because
somebody is infatuated with us suddenly
they look a little bit better
well naturally like other people like us
that may not do it for a lot of cases
right there could be well I still don't
like them it's nice that they like them
but the same thing with other you know
likings of that way he says a man's
conscience accuses itself isn't that if
he does not love one who loves him or
respond in love to love seeking nothing
from the other but the evidences of his
love they were talking about love and
friendship in a very different way than
we were with Plato or Aristotle or
Cicero epicurus we're in something
that's much more like what you guys had
already experienced in your
middle-school crushes high school
friendships whatever it is that you're
doing here as adults in college and what
you're going to be doing the rest of
your life so that's where we'll leave
off for today